our next guest says that while the media
will be reflexively antitrump they'll
not have their reliable Muller stories
to obsess over in fact they might have
to confront some hard truths about what
really happened with these new
investigations coming to fruition Victor
Davis Hanson senior fellow at the Hoover
Institution joins us now Victor good to
have you back ok you have some big
predictions about what stories will
dominate ahead of the 2020 election tell
us well I think the Muller story is
pretty much through Laura and it's kind
of like a boomerang effect that now
we're going to see that the people who
were instrumental in subverting the
Trump campaign transition indeed the
presidency are going to be called to
account so we heard that walls are
closing in the noose is tightening but
it's gonna act in Reverse so Comey
brennan mccabe Bruce oar and his wife
they're all facing either criminal
referrals are likely criminal referrals
and this is going to be a lows a slow
drawn-out process all the way to the
2020 elections and then when you see you
mentioned the good economy that that's
something that Trump needs to focus I
think even more on but the two areas in
the new cycle where he might be
vulnerable we've had a million illegal
aliens coming just in half a year
there's no alternative from the
Democrats I mean this is that he wanted
to shut down the government and he did
to stop the illegal immigration he
wanted to be put it tariffs and he would
have on Mexico so he's doing all he can
so that's not gonna be an issue for the
Democrats because they can't say well we
would we would stop immigration because
they want more of it illegally and then
finally we've got a big annual deficit
and Trump might be vulnerable there but
the Democrats are not you know they
don't have a reputation for physical
sobriety so areas where talk might be
vulnerable they're not that they can't
they know for nor can any worse
reparations be worse on all they're
gonna be worse on the border they're
gonna be worse on spending they're gonna
be they're gonna be worse on all those
things that he might be vulnerable on in
another another type of election I have
to get to this ABC released part of a
George Stephanopoulos exclusive
interview with President Trump and it's
getting wall-to-wall coverage on the
networks take a look the foreigners if
Russia if China if someone else
offers the information on opponent
should they accept it or should they
call the FBI I think maybe you do both I
think you might want to listen I don't
there's nothing wrong with listening if
somebody called from a country Norway we
have information on your opponent oh I
think I'd want to hear you want that
kind of interference in our elections
it's not an interference they have
information I think I'd take it if I
thought there was something wrong I'd go
maybe to the FBI if I thought there was
something wrong
Victor setting aside the question of why
you would have George Stephanopoulos
standing over the president and the Oval
Office I don't know who approved that
but what about this notion of accepting
foreign Intel about an opponent is that
a risk for president Trump getting
pulled back in the Muller again why he
was put in that situation is beyond me
well you hit the nail on the head you
shouldn't ever talk to George
Stephanopoulos one into any question
about foreign intelligence that should
be at the end of conversation because it
can be manipulated and distorted what
Trump was probably doing saying I think
he intended to say something like Adam
Schiff who got full wimmer by those
Russian comedians have called him up and
said I've got dirt and Adam Schiff
seemed very eager to hear it that's what
Trump might say and and we hear all all
these politicians here this type of
stuff from all sources but I think the
cardinal rule is in Trump's case you
don't even discuss that you just
Stephanopoulos there a little bit I mean
he joked about what he said Russia get
the aim and get Hillary's emails I mean
that was obviously a trump joke but
again putting and putting him in that
situation was good I don't I don't get
it Victor we're out of time thank you so
much it's great to have you back